Well guys, I want to say I'm happy that we filled most of the
podcast time with not this, but Hutch really wanted to talk about
collar gate. So, thank god there's only a few >> Oh.
Oh, that's
dude. That's brutal right off the bat.
Oh my god,
that's throwing him under the under the bus so hard right there.
Like, none of us give a about this. We're wasting our time. But
I guess Hutch just has to talk about it. Hutch just needs this
to be a thing. Hutch can't just let this go. So, I guess we'll
go do it cuz this guy won't shut the up about it. Amazing. >> Few
minutes left to talk about it. But >> what what is the
context, Hutch? Why is this itching you? Why is what has been
this shocking revelation, if you will? >> Well, I mean,
I think it's like uh I think it's a really
funny kind of internet moment, you know, it kind of it did kind
of blow up after last week and uh uh what? Sorry, what question
did you ask me again? Like >> I'm What is What is so pertinent?
Okay, so when I see this for the the audience members who don't
know Oh, can I move my avatar back? Yes, I can. Hold on.
Ka,
get over here. I'm I don't know if I could do it again. Can I
do it again while I shot Kai again?
I don't I don't know. Hold on,
bro. This loop is This loop is a long time. I'm like trying to
wait for it.
Place. Place dog. Go to your place.
Yeah, that's what I thought. That's what I thought.
>> You know, if you've been living under a rock, everyone's
accusing Hassan [__] of shocking his dog so that
she sits in frame for hours on end. As >> Bro, I think
I'm uh
I had like almost nothing to drink yesterday. I think I am feeling
like a hangover. I am like hung over today. It's like tragic.
I didn't drink any water. I had like very I didn't have that
much alcohol, but I had no water at all. And I just I'm That's
what it is today. I give >> a prop. And um you know, my
hot take is one, I've seen people use shot collars and they're
totally fine. But if the reason he's using it, if he does have
one, is to just make her sit there all day, yeah, it's pretty
messed up. But ultimately, does this really affect like anything?
Uh you know, we're talking about missing the forest for the trees
with this
Newsome bill. This is so far beyond that. I couldn't even criticize
like Pisco for bringing that up when you know you got half the
internet blasting this Hassan stuff and it's just like I just
don't care about this drama slop. So I'm curious and I'm not
authority.
>> Sophia with the seven gifted out of nowhere adding two
hours to the stream. You love to see it. Thank you very much
Sophia. Super appreciate it. Also welcome back. I noticed you
you hadn't um
I don't know if you haven't been chatting recently. I feel like
you hadn't, but welcome back. Thank you very much for the for
the donation. You know, I'm out here panhandling and Sophia comes
down like Mercy, okay, in the Overwatch skit and like helps me
out of the rubble. Thank you so much. Thank you. Thank you. All
right, let's uh we added the time. Let's continue on with the
content. >> Am I trying to talk too much? >> It's
not so much the It's not So, so first of all, we can walk and
chew bubble gum at the same time. So, if some story blows up
on the internet for a week, it doesn't mean you don't care about
like Trump's authoritarianism or whatever. Um, but I think >> the
genocide not going on right now, Hutch. You can't criticize the
song. >> Uh, I think like what made the story like so big
is not even necessarily the incident. It's just everything that
followed after the incident because it felt like at every step
he made the kind
>> I don't even know if it was like bad, but like realistically
the the whole way. Oh, she has been. Well, I I haven't seen Sophia.
I see Sophia sometimes. Maybe she's just busy. Okay. But I have
seen Sophia type sometimes. She just, you know, she's busy. I
get it though. And that's maybe the best for everybody. Okay,
we're happy to hear Sophia's busy or I don't know. I'm making
things up. I just need to go. >> He kind of striand himself.
>> Um, sorry. I need to go back to me to actually talk
about Hutch. Um,
oh, it's funny that like this is this is what you hear people
do when you know that like a controversy is kind of contrived.
They go like, "Well, technically like the thing that kicked this
controversy controversy off isn't that big a deal, but
but even though it's not that big a deal, uh, the way he handled
it, the way it like proceeded over time, that's what lets you
know how he's really up.
And by the way, I can believe that, but I'll never believe that
it's like a bigger controversy,
right? I'll never believe it's a bigger
than the actual like impetus.
It can't be bigger. Like their reaction to something can't really
be that much bigger unless they're doing something crazy. And
like realistically at worst Hassan did some Machavevelian to
try to not like let his reputation get dragged through the mud,
right? Like he lied. Which again like that that would be weird.
It would say a lot about him, but I don't even know that he did
necessarily
other than maybe talking about the caller being able to shock,
yeah, but pirate pirate continued to feed, right? That's the
that's the issue is like Hassan made one statement and then he
moved forward. Pirate continued to feed into it, right?
Hassan's doing the smart thing. He's not feeding into it anymore.
>> Just made the whole PR disaster for him. I think even
worse. Um cuz cuz when you do like look at the body of evidence,
it seems like pretty explicitly obvious that he was lying about
the whole thing. And I think it's just like a good cautionary
tale for why you don't stand creators. Like when you stand creators,
like you you will find or even politicians or celebrities, you
will find your brain will find a way to avoid confronting things
that are just like self-evidently true to everybody outside of
that group. Wasn't there a new clip of of with with Hassan saying
it was opening the gate? >> Huh? I don't even know what
you mean. And haven't seen it. >> I mean, I think like
I think what made the story interesting is like, you know, like
you have someone like Hassan who goes beyond
um like ideology and and you know, politics. Like a lot of what
he frames his content around is about like strong moral judgments.
And so anytime you have someone who That's a big
There's no way. Hold on. There's no way he could possibly make
this argument right now, right? I'm sorry.
Does he not realize what he's doing when he makes this argument?
Please don't say please don't say the thing that we all know
that's like, well, when you have somebody who makes moral judgments,
you know, politics is downstream immorality and obviously we
can't take somebody's political opinion seriously when they've
shown themselves to be a total moral repbate. He can't say that
right now, right? Because while that is true, I don't think I
don't think that's
that could get dicey for him given where his audience is coming
from right now. That's all >> content around is about like
strong moral judgments. And so anytime you have someone who that's
a big part of their content and then you know they get caught
doing something like this, that's going to invite an extreme
reaction from a lot of different corners of the internet. So
I don't know. You guys don't seem like you were deeply invested
in this. >> Not super invested in it. I mean, we don't
need to get into deep. Yeah. Go >> From what it looks like,
it it looks like it was um that he was using that collar, right?
Or that he was using uh to keep the dog in frame. I mean, I wouldn't
do that, but what is the what should be done to him? I don't
know. >> Do you condemn Yes or no? Pisco, >> I I
wouldn't do it. So, I guess I
>> Well, you're I'll say I haven't paid too much attention
to it, but um Hassan is a known liar. He lied about getting kicked
out of the DNC. He made a whole video titled, "I got kicked out
of the DNC when all they did was ask him to leave a certain area
because someone more important came along." So, this is like
one of those framing things where I just think it's like so disingenuous,
right? Like IRI should know this because he had an interview
from somebody who was using the public Wi-Fi there where you
couldn't hear anything he said. It was just chopping in and out
constantly. And Assan said to the people who are kicking him
out, "Well, I'm going to have to leave because the internet is
not good enough here to support streaming. I need the hardline
that's in this booth that's in this like balcony in this uh what
do you call it? It's uh oh, it's not a balcony. It's like uh
it's like a box seat at an arena or whatever, right?" And he
needed the hardwired connection to stream.
So that's what he said. And then they were like, "No, no, no.
We can't let you stay here." And he's like, "Okay, I'm gonna
have to go then." And he he said that was getting kicked out.
I think that is getting kicked out of the spot where you can
do your job. I don't think that's I don't think that's a lie.
I understand that might be like self victimizing, but they literally
walked him out.
They literally like walked with him to the door and they took
his press credentials for that like floor in
I don't think that's crazy. He can't do the thing. He that he
was planning to stream while he was there. He can't do that from
the main area. He's watched everybody else's streams cut out.
That's like maybe hyperbolic. That's the worst thing. I don't
know if Nick's commented on it yet. We'll see. Uh >> this
guy is known to not tell the truth. And uh I think he he his
dog was being shocked. I don't give a [__] what all
his little supporters say. And he he tried to back away with
it. And you did the investigation, Hutch, and seemed to uncover
some details. >> Bro, we went deep, man. We went deep.
So, I think he's full of I think he his dog It's not natural
for a dog to sit there for 5 hours and not get up. So, I don't
know. >> Which literally doesn't happen. I You'd think
when you're on a soapbox about lying, you wouldn't just make
up details of the story, right? You'd think like that's just
me. It's like, "Oh, I'm going to talk about how like lying is
bad. Misframing things and being hyperbolic in a story is bad."
I would not want to do that same thing if I was making that point
like while making the point like within a like crafting a statement
that you are actually kicking yourself in the balls while you
make the statement seems insane to me right it's so bad to lie
and Israel got JFK shot like lying is so totally wrong you should
never trust somebody who lies and we faked the moon landing like
why are you why are you doing that
right I don't understand why you would do that it just seems
like
>> know what's going on but I don't put anything past the
guy and I don't know seems like a situation all around
>> there there's stuff about it that like so like there
was so if you take the image of cuz he he did this whole thing
where he pulled out the collar and he like showed his stream
but he did it in the most suspicious bizarre way you could possibly
imagine uh and and when you you know you take a still image of
his stream and then you know what I did was like I took a still
image and then I put it in OBS And then I all I did was I just
turn the contrast up. That's it. I did it live on stream. And
it's really apparent that there's a strip of electrical tape
covering where the like prong
uh whatever prong situation is. And then also the serial number.
And >> why didn't he explain why didn't he explain the
prong situation? >> And uh like >> he's also holding
it like I don't know if you've ever seen like a girl or a boy
in a relationship, right? Like they try to show you something
on their phone, but they really don't want you to grab it and
look at their text. So they're just kind of like, you know, oh,
I listen, if you want to go inside the mind of Pisco right now,
okay, if you want to go inside the mind of Pisco, here's here's
inside the mind of Pisco right now. Like, man, these guys sure
are doing like a lot of narrativizing here instead of just instead
of just like saying facts, they're doing a lot of narrativeizing.
I I literally just, you know, I literally just po pointed out
that Ethan was totally lying about his li lawsuits recently.
Um, legal mindset was totally lying about those lawsuits. Asmin
go was totally I I've already like kind of picked these people
off. So, I'm going to let this one go, but me like uh any other
situation. It's just I would have to ask more questions here
cuz they're just they're clearly narrativizing this as hard as
they can. That's in Pisco's mind. Okay, that's in Pisco's mind.
That's what he's thinking. He like he knows he's like I don't
have any reason to step out on this. It's like something that's
nonsensical. I'm just going to say it's silly. But he has to
know that this is how this this sounds like totally narrativeized
in just a weird way, right? When you're like, "Oh, he's he's
actually like a like a girl who doesn't want to show you her
phone."
I don't think any of that was like particularly weird. I do think
the tape was odd and the tape was clearly there and he's not
answering. So, that makes me think it's like a caller that can
shock. And now we've seen the remote. We know that it's from
that company. So, >> yeah. No, check out this meme. And
it's like, hold on, let me hold it. No, no, no, no, no. Yeah,
he's kind of like covering a bunch of it up with his fingers.
Like, don't get me wrong, by the way, like all of my talking
about like why are we talking about this? It does seem like it
is really awful. Uh like it it it looks pretty bad given everything
that I've seen you cover, Hutch. So, yeah. But it m it makes
like what he did afterwards like pretty despicable because like
you know Moist critical made a video where he was talking about
the thing for like 20 minutes and you know he he was pretty harsh
on Hassan and you know recognized some like really obvious problems
with what Hassan was saying and then Hassan like you know like
shhat on moist critical and accused him of just like jumping
on the bandwagon and it's like it goes beyond just a lie about
the caller you know that's wait did Hassan sh on critical or
did he say he jumped on the bandwagon because I swear to God
Moy critical did just jump on the
I don't know if that's like horrible. That's like literally all
Charlie's ever done. Hi guys, it's uh it's me, Charlie, here.
And uh just so you know, I I do sound like Eeyore from Winnie
the Pooh. Yeah, that's true. Uh just so you know, I'm going to
cover the most popular thing from Reddit this week again for
the 30th week in a row. Here's the here's the take that was the
average highest comment on the Reddit thread. Here it is. >> Like
that would have been bad, I think. But I think he would have
survived it if he would have just said like, "Yeah, you know,
this is what I'm using and whatever. I can talk to trainer and,
you know, explore the ethics of it or whatever." And it would
have been bad PR, but it wouldn't have been career ending. But
the fact that he like he's going so hard and like I feel like
>> it wouldn't have been career ending. Implying that what's
happening now is currently career ending.
Hold on. I need to I need to check it out. Can we see what career
ending is for Hassan [__] channel Hassanabi? Okay,
let me see what career ending was today. career ending is uh
33,000 viewers, an average of 30,000 viewers, a per peak of 34,000
Uh let's see. Seems like he's about averaging and peaking at
the same thing the whole week. Seems like there's no real issues.
Oh, maybe this is an issue. He's having sub bleed off over the
past week. He lost uh what? Over the past week, he's lost
2,971,892.
2 million. Hold on. What? What is the number? Can I get the number
here?
970,000.
And down here we're 9. So about 6,000 subs over
out of nearly 3 million. About 6,000 subs over the past week.
Is that the Is that like one of his only fall-offs here? Did
he have some sub loss? There was So there is some sub loss here.
This is true. It doesn't make up for whatever he did on October
5th when he gained a subs.
October 5th, October 6th, he gained a subs. He's had a little
bleed off now.
Wow. Oh, sorry. I'm saying subs. I mean follows. I mean follows.
I'm thinking of subs as on as in on kick, but it's it's
Okay. This is tremendously career ending right now. Damn. Career
ended. >> There's something I feel like that should be
really taboo. And when you do what we do, like when you're doing
>> I was talking about followers there, Neosc followers.
I was using the wrong lingo. and you have an audience and you
manipulate your audience in that way and then you mobilize them
against people that are criticizing you for doing something that
you very obviously did. That's like a level of manipulation that
we're getting close to like MAGA territory and uh you know I
think like
who I've never heard of this before. Hold on. Tell me. >> And
you have an audience. And you manipulate your audience in that
way. And then you >> you manipulate your audience by lying
to them and saying you didn't do the bad thing and that only
evil people are attacking you who say the bad thing. Did Hassan
do something crazy? Like did he say like anybody who who's saying
these things, anybody who's talking about this actually deserves
to be killed. They should be killed. Or did he go like way less
far than somebody you regularly
respect the opinions of? you mobilize them against people that
are criticizing you for doing something that you very obviously
did. That's like a level of manipulation that we're getting close
to like MAGA territory. And
>> dude, it's like
I
I guess people never think about like what you can infer from
the things they're saying, right? Like anything to sort of downstream,
they don't think about it at all.
>> No, I think like there should be social consequences
for doing stuff like that. >> no. Yeah. Yeah. Let me add
to that because I think that is more important to bring up other
than this event and like how maybe inconsequential it could be.
The idea that we lionize these creators and I constantly try
to hammer this into my audience. I'm not special. I'm not better
than you. My opinions you might respect, but if you're holding
me up as some like messiahic figure and hanging on my every word
that is uh
>> is a recipe for failure. And these people that indulge
in that and they want that to be part of their brand will do
what you're talking about, which is like what Trump does, which
is, hey, there is no longer a a space for criticism of me that
I will ever validate. I am going to have my minions like perpetuate
whatever excuse or lie and deny, deny, deny and create this media
bubble that makes it impossible to ever change or shape or move
in a positive direction. It is incredibly harmful and toxic the
way that >> it it really is. It really really is. I see
soy pill appears to be in a in a in a suite right now.
Would that be for un America or
>> These creators can sometimes uh get trapped in these
these positions of of uh authority? I so I do agree with that.
>> Yeah. Like how hard would it have been to just say,
you know what, a trainer advised me to get this certain caller
and I I tried it and you guys are right. I don't like what happened
and uh the
collar is not going to be used anymore and um you know it's it's
not the end of the world man like holy sh dude
maybe because he knows that he shouldn't or I I mean I don't
know anything about dogs like my intuition is as someone who
doesn't have dogs and has never I love dogs but I've never like
owned a dog is that they shouldn't be in one place for hours
and hours and hours and hours and hours maybe but they're also
are dogs that that stay for a long time. My intuition is that
what people have a problem with is using the dog as a prop and
doing things that are in the not in the best interest of the
dog and admitting that like yeah, I did do this thing for my
stream and not necessarily for the best interest of the dog.
Um I I think maybe that's a a straw too much.
>> Well, I don't think that happened, right? What I think
what I think happened is listen, you want to train the dog to
stay in a certain place for several hours, right? You want to
train the dog to not rest on its joints. This is what he says.
I don't know if this is true, okay? But this is what he says.
He wants to train the dog to stay in a place so it's on something
that's like more evenly spreading out the weight of the dog than
a hard floor would. Right, that's fine. Now, he needs to do that.
If he wanted to do that anyway,
what's wrong with him doing that in a place where it's going
to happen on stream,
right? What I would it be significantly worse if he did it somewhere
else and just put a camera on Ka?
I don't know. >> There's there's like there's definitely
debate about like the ethics of even just using vibration. >> No,
why wouldn't he why wouldn't he just put Ka in like a different
room with a
Like that that would be the same.
I just Yeah. And again,
so for me, the thing that makes it like quite a bit different
is if Hassan was doing this and if Hassan didn't take care of
his dog, if he wasn't committed to caring for his dog, right?
I would have a lot bigger problem with any of the things that
have happened here. But the thing is, he he does take care of
the dog. He does take the dog out every day. Make sure the dog
is when he's not there, take it out every day to go for walks,
go for runs. Like, he's a incredibly well-taken care of dog,
right? I will accept a higher level of of training and discipline
requirement from somebody who's willing to put the time in on
their side to make sure that that like they've you know they're
reciprocating the what would you call it like the the level of
dedication they require from the dog is reciprocated back to
the dog.
That's
kind of that that sort of is the
the morality of how I feel
about or sorry that I guess how I judge the situation situation
from like a moral perspective is I think if you're willing to
put all of this discipline into taking care of the dog right
you can have that level of expectation from the dog and it's
not crazyation
callers for example beyond just uh shot collars um but one thing
that you'll always hear from I mean this is just like I did a
lot of studying about this like over the last week cuz I didn't
really know much about like the debate. One thing that's not
really debated is that it has to be done like in the context
of like positive reinforcement. So if your dog is like, you know,
getting off of a bed or whatever, I think almost all trainers
will tell you that you do not have to purely use positive reinforcement
on dogs and that a purely positive reinforcement approach is
actually not good. Like it is actually not the most effective.
Positive reinforcement is good. You should probably use positive
reinforcement where you can, but having no negative reinforcement,
there are some behaviors you just want to weed out entirely.
You can't only positively reinforce other behaviors. Sometimes
there are things you need to weed out and then you zap it just
with no other context or anything like that. Then you're creating
this situation where the dog feels like they're on edge. They're
going to be anxious. They're not necessarily going to know like
when that's happening. If you do it in the context of like, you
know, proper training, you know, type setting with positive reinforcement,
then you can find some trainers that say that it's appropriate
to use it, especially if you have like dogs that are, you know,
very
poorly behaved. But in the context, >> are you saying that
the the collar itself is you don't think is inhumane? >> Well,
no. I mean, like I so I've never used a shot collar. My family
has. I've never liked it. You know what I mean? Like I would
never buy one personally. I don't love seeing dogs, you know,
like yelp when they get that kind of >> I'm asking I'm
asking I can do wait. I'm not sorry. I really >> listen.
Soy pill Hutch Hutch is his boy. Let Pisco talk. Let Pisco cook.
>> Triggered. I'm asking the specific thing which is do
you think it's inhumane to have that color? >> I do. Yeah.
I do. Yeah. >> But but I also >> Let me counter that.
Let me counter this because Okay. In my >> But so
you you don't see what Pisco does there, right? I I hate to I
hate to blow Pisco's spot up, okay? Because he probably doesn't
want to get in fights here, but he's just like, "Can I take the
He just asked a question that's just a filtering question. Should
I have any further conversation on this topic with Hutch?" Okay.
Do you think that caller in and of itself is abusive?
Hutch says, "Yes." Pisco just goes, "Okay." Right. You can just
opt out of the conversation entirely now.
Entirely. Like Hutch has actually just exposed himself as a complete
[__] with that opinion.
>> Experience. I I was friends with a very rich family
and they had the most annoying Pomeranian that you have ever
encountered. It would not shut the up. And these people were
very wealthy. They tried trainers. They tried like everything
in the book. And finally what they settled on was they'll get
a shock collar which you know I've tried it on and I think it's
more intense for us cuz we don't have the hair. It does give
you a little jolt but nothing more crazy than like it's not like
it doesn't hurt. It's like
your muscles tense up. It does shock you in so far as it expecting
it to come. The dog does not understand electricity. It doesn't
know what's happening for for as all it knows is it's coming
out of nowhere, right? It doesn't even know the owner is doing
it to it. And what it does is you do it a couple times.
>> No, no, no, no, no. I think I think dogs very readily
understand that it's the owner doing it. Like if you're if you're
using a this collar as like a corrective measure, right? You
expect a behavior after you correct. Or you could you could even
use it I think some people it seemed like Lyan said you can use
it for like just a command like not even as a negative correction.
It's like a hey, I need your attention. It'd be like snapping
your fingers, right? It's like it's such a at such a low level.
It's basically like tapping the dog in the shoulder, right? And
Lykan knows quite a bit about about that stuff. Like he looks
into that stuff quite a bit. I don't think that's unsupported
that you can use it that ways
and it the negative reinforcement of oh head off when someone
new comes in the door. I get a little and I don't like that and
then they stop after a while. It's not this like thing that you're
constantly doing. I think the issue is not so much as the shock
because we use like shocks or electric fences. >> Dogs
don't understand understand causality.
Um, wait. I thought there was some evidence that they understand
causality. Or like, are you saying that you could train these
pathways into them, but they don't understand causality? Cuz
like everybody knows that if you train a dog to go outside uh
to go to the bathroom, you give them a treat if they go to the
bathroom outside that when your dog dog comes back inside, they
sit there and expect a
you could call it conditioning, I guess, if it's purely conditioning.
I thought there was some evidence that they could understand
parts of causality, but it's fine. is to like show animals this
is a thing that you shouldn't do and it works in the long run.
You don't have to like
hear like mix though soy bill because on the one hand you have
people who are like this should never be used as inhumane like
this is like these kinds of instruments are abuse by themselves
and that's I'm getting tons of mixed messaging on that based
on again just being on Twitter and seeing that stuff. Um, and
then there are other people like, "No, no, these are tools that
have good purposes and can result in good outcomes for the owner
and for the dog. The problem is how it's used." And so when that
happens, I I as someone who's not a dog expert, I have to throw
my hands up and say like, I don't know enough to know that this
isn't a useful instrument sometimes,
>> right? But I think again the issue we're taking with
Sorry. All right. Let me say that what I was going to say is
that the issue we're taking with is not well me. I know. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Hutch just said the opposite. Soy pill is about to say,
"Well, the issue we're taking with it with is how Hassan's using
it. It's not just that it's bad, but no, Hutch just said it was
bad on its own. That's a dude. Pisco Pisco like badly doesn't
want to pick another fight with Hutch on something. He's like
trying to let this go as much as he can, but there's this part
of him that will not let it go entirely, right?
So that Pisco says being on Twitter instead of from Hutch two
minutes ago.
He did, but like you're right because he did hear from Hutch
two minutes ago. He says it on Twitter because he wants to imply
that it's like pretty crazy. Somebody who I'm definitely not
referring to directly. Like people on Twitter seem to be implying
that this tool is bad in and of itself. And you know, me is not
an expert. I would never make that claim cuz that seems like
a claim you'd want to rely on some expertise for. So I think
you'd kind of look like a total [__] on Twitter if
you said this, right? Like I think only a would say that. So
I'm not referring to anybody directly. I'm just kind of putting
it out into the ether. or the people on Twitter, they should
understand that that would be a silly opinion to have.
>> Some people are like, "Chocolate should never be used."
But I see it as the same as, you know, that dog trainer, the
dog whist, you know, he gives the two fingers in the neck. He's
like, "It, you know, like don't do that. It right like it's just
a little like, hey, don't do this sort of thing." But when you're
using it to enforce a behavior that does not make any sense was,
hey, don't get up and go to your water bowl. Don't come up and
give me licks. Stay in your spot, which is right here in the
specific spot on my stream camera. That's the kind of cruel and
inhumane part is like the dog doesn't know what the hell's going
on. It doesn't know what a stream is and you're kind of forcing
it to stand still for your image. That's what's up about using
it there. But I you were saying >> well I had a dog for
10 years and I can tell you that any problem with a dog's misbehavior
is the owner's fault. It is misbehavior by the owner. Don't know
what the hell they're doing. No dog is going to act up or do
stupid things unless you are mistreating it in your kitchen.
It barks at people. It does things. It tears things up. It's
all >> This is like I don't even I don't totally disagree
with this. What do you like? Hold on. I I think like basically
a lot of bad behaviors could be trained out of a dog. Like I
would say a one-off thing that happens. I don't agree with this.
Right.
Highrise apartment is the size of Hutch's stream room. So this
is we're okay. I think I think this could be a fine opinion that
you like blame Oh, Hassan stream. I see.
man, I I think this is like not a terrible opinion that like
most dogs are
their bad behavior is the result of bad ownership. I think that
tends to be the case or at least like um ownership that's stretched
thin in terms of how much time they could spend with the dog.
I don't really think that's like the wrong direction for an opinion,
but I don't think Kai did anything wrong. I don't think anybody's
really in the wrong here other than Hassan if he did use the
stimulus to um to correct the dog from getting off when he was
like
>> Your fault as the owner >> mostly just cuz the
dog was already getting back on the thing, right? The dog was
already turning back around and like being like, "Okay, I get
it." >> So, this is a shortcut to try to like rewire an
animal's brain to force them to do something you want because
you failed as an as an a dog owner. Now, I don't know if that's
the case with Assan. I have no idea, but I can only see one use
for a shot collar. That's if you have some outdoor dog that you
don't want running into the neighbor's yard or something and
it hits it when it goes to a certain area. How else could you
teach a jo dog not to run into a certain area or something like
that? But I think there's absolutely no excuse to have a shot
collar on an indoor dog. That's
>> What do you think of my my Pomeranian anecdote? Do you
think that like it seems like they were out of options? >> They
up. They did something wrong. they up that that and that they
need to learn positive reinforcement or they're doing something
that's causing the dog to go haywire. They're probably screaming
every time the door comes on or a doorbell rings or something.
I don't
>> you were saying >> I think it's a shortcut. I
think it's a cruel shortcut that's unnecessary and it being a
dog owner requires patience and responsibility and you're you're
signing up for a lot more than people realize. It's not your
prop that you just play with and then leave it. It's it's a member
of the family. It requires a lot of work and a and a lot of patience.
>> I again I agree with all of that. I just don't like
how pe people like anthropomorphize this. They they feel like
the dog just like understands.
They feel like the dog has like this will that needs to be respected
all the time. Um there are things the dog will want to do that
it's like, "Hey, I would rather you stay there right now." And
the the situation described, I've not seen anybody like dispute
this. The dog goes out in the morning, they go for runs, they
go like spend a bunch of time getting exercise, getting their
energy out, and then they come home and they're supposed to lay
down for like three
right? And then the dog gets up and it goes outside again. That
seems to be the cadence they follow most of the time. I don't
see how that is abusive. I I do not see it. I cannot see it.
Dog's never panting like it's thirsty when it comes back in there.
So I I just don't get how everybody paints this in a certain
way. Like they paint it as like this crazy.
>> Well, it the whole thing just got so much worse too
because like on Friday like people started like I started I got
really skitso with it you guys. Like I started going through
like all of his old VODs and I was like tracking like when the
dog moved. And so like anytime the dog like moved position, I
would like go back a few frames and like and there were like
no less than like five or six potential times where he would
he would he would look back and he would see the dog moved and
then he would look to the right like on this particular part
of his desk, move his arm, and then the dog would kind of go
like that and like get back on the bed. And so >> how can
you be so sure that the >> Wait, wait, wait. Why do I not
have a super cut of this from Hutch's stream? Do we not have
a super cut of this? I want to see this. If he's gone and said,
"Oh, when he when he sees Ka move, Hassan's going to go and hit
the button." Let's take a look.
Oh my gosh.
I want to see that, man. >> The uh stress of seeing his
dog move out of frame isn't causing him to want to take a Zen
and put it in his mouth. >> Uh Nyx, can you show me an
example of the dog lying in the same spot for 6 hours?
Can you find me a VOD where that happens? cuz I couldn't find
I only went back like a week, but I couldn't find a VOD where
she was there for six hours. Like it was three hours pretty much
on the dot every time. It seemed like Hassan's mom would come
home from something and take the dog out again.
But maybe maybe I'm misunderstanding or maybe it's like a very
obvious case where it happens like 6 hours. Actually, could you
get me two at the 5 to 6 hour mark? If you could find those,
I would watch them right now. >> Oh, that's fair. That's
fair. Yeah. No, but like the whole thing reached a whole new
level of kind of because like I think a couple days ago he was,
you know, he was doing his >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, here's
what I expect. Okay. Here's what I expect, J. I expect what I
expect to happen is at about 3 hours, his mom comes home or something
and she usually grabs the dog or something, right?
What I would expect sometimes is the mom doesn't come home and
Hzan doesn't think about it cuz he's doing his job and the dog
sits there for a little longer cuz the dog doesn't make any noise.
I'm guessing if the dog like starts saying like, oh, like starts
getting up or or like saying it wants to go out, I would assume
he looks at the time and goes, oh yeah, this is around the time
you normally go out. Something got to be done.
That's that's how I'd expect it to happen.
Um, but if somebody can find something that goes against >> the
stream and then he has his dog on his lap and he was just like
uh he he was lamenting to his stream. He's like, "You know what?
Now because everybody's being so mean to me because of this,
now I guess I just can't discipline my dog." So, it was like
a new level of kind of like emotional manipulation that I found
to be quite deplorable when you think about it, you know? Like
I think it's pretty obvious that he knew that his audience would
not approve of that. But >> wait, what? I think I think
he that's just correct, isn't it? Like he's going to have a hard
time keeping his dog on stream like in frame now. I would assume
that's that's just true. >> He personally doesn't think
there's anything immoral like immoral about doing it. he got
caught and now he's resentful at the people who caught him doing
it for, you know, because now he's just he's got to change everything.
He can't be like as strict about the dog being on that bed anymore
because it's just going to invite more scrutiny. And so he he
blamed them like he blamed like the people that caught him doing
it, which is pretty wild. >> I I think I also heard you
said the dog caught its paw on the bed or something like that.
If that happened, the dog would be licking its paw instantly.
It wouldn't just sit there and wonder what happened out. You
know, dogs aren't idiots. It's like if something hurts, they're
going to go to where it hurts and try to mess with it. >> Well,
they wouldn't put the ball the paw right back down. Like if you're
if your dog hurts their paw, they would like limp a little bit.
They would like lick it, whatever. They wouldn't put the paw
immediately down on the bed immediately after hurting it. >> They're
not just sitting there. Wow, something hurt me. >> I like
I do like that a bunch of them said, "Okay, I don't care about
this." And that now IRI is like kind of invested. Had like a
whole take. Soy pill seems to be a little more invested. They're
like, "No, Hutch, don't talk about it." Oh, well, if you're going
to talk about it, I guess we'll throw our two senses. >> Let
me stare into space and think about it. Like, no, they would
go look investigate the situation immediately. They're just,
you know, >> is he is he denying that he buzzed buzzed
it or >> He said the dog got its paw cut on the bed or
something and it wasn't even wearing a shotgun. >> Wait,
wait, that's not the same as that. So, I think the biggest, you
know, sus sign is if you didn't shock him or if you didn't buzz
him, you would just say, "I did not do this." But he's saying
he the dog got caught there or I think he got caught. That's
different than saying I absolutely did not press the button.
That to me is sus. >> Well, so here we can we can end it
on this. I just want to like here's what I think is the most
damning thing. Okay, so like just put yourself in in his shoes,
okay? Like let's let's say you're not wearing a collar, you're
streaming and your dog yelps a little bit and then an maybe an
hour or two hours later your chat is telling you like it's going
viral. It's getting picked up on LSF, you know, like tweets are
going going off 20,000 40,000 likes like uh they're accusing
you of shocking your dog. Like what would you do? Like >> you
didn't you didn't immediately pull the collar off and show everybody
right then in that moment.
>> Take the collar off, show it.
Pisco won't be able to go along with this, I don't think. Anonymous,
thank you for the gifted sub. I think Pisco, doesn't Pisco have
to maintain like innocent until proven guilty? I don't think
Pisco can go along with this one that like, well, he didn't immediately
like show his innocence, that means he's guilty. I think he I
think he'll naturally bristle at this.
>> I think we'll see.
>> Right then there, >> right there. Right. You would
walk up and you would just take the call off and you would show
him like, "Hey, look." And you wouldn't do this weird thing that
he did where he's doing all that stuff like
it. He >> I think if if he didn't shock it or he didn't
buzz. I don't know. Is it a shock collar? Did he shock it? >> Yeah,
it was a shot collar 100%. >> Okay. Okay. But did he do
we know that he shocked as opposed cuz there were some it was
like buzzing versus shocking. I don't know. He cla He claims
when he showed the call, he's like, "See, it can do a vibration,
but he wouldn't even say that he uses it to vibrate her." Cuz
he would, you know, that's even more plausible if he were to
come out and be like, "Oh, yeah, no, I I did buzz her, but I
just do a little vibration. It doesn't hurt." But he was, he's
not even admitting that. He's like, "Here's the collar. It doesn't
even shock. Can't do that. It can't vibrate, but I don't do that."
>> If you didn't if you didn't do something with that button,
you would say, "I did not press any button." You would say, "Of
course, I didn't do that thing." But the fact that he's not doing
it means he probably shocked her.
There's no way to explain that he didn't that him not doing that.
There's just no way to logically explain that because he he also
went on to say like this is the worst PR crisis he's ever faced.
And so he obviously So >> is it really
the 911 thing? >> It is way wor Yeah. It's by far the worst
PR crisis he's ever had. >> Yeah, I think that's obvious
like in terms of the negative the negative PR you get across
the internet from this. >> Well, no. And it's and it's
true. You know, people get especially in America like with dogs,
you know, but like if that is the case, right? Like if you if
you seriously think that this is the worst PR crisis that you've
ever faced, you have the strongest incentive to just immediately
take the collar off and just show it and for what it is and you
know, without any kind of ambiguity and without any of the weird
[__] that he did, he didn't do that. And there's
no way to explain that unless he has a shot caller. Like there's
just no way to explain it. So anyways,
>> th this is I just like Okay, I have to do the thing
where I take a little lap of my own. Like I said when it first
happened, Hassan should do that. In my opinion, if it isn't a
caller because now if he doesn't do it, everybody will say the
only reason for not doing it is uh is just because it's obviously
a shot caller or he obviously shocked the dog. Right. In my opinion,
Hassan's got a
storied history of refusing to admit um refusing to even comment
on things that would he would just be way better off commenting
on, right? Leaving a lot of his support for Houthies and their
actions like ambiguous at times or straight up like leaning into
it and not saying, you know, he he has two positions. One is
it's never okay to target civilians and the other one is I support
the Houthies 10 to 10 toes down even though they kidnap civilians.
those two positions don't work, right? And I I do believe the
first position is his ultimate one, but he's also said this thing
where you can't you can't ever when people say you support terrorists,
you can't like concede to them and say like, "Yeah, this was
a terrorist action." Right? So that that belief, that third belief
explains the second one that doesn't make sense with everything
else. So I feel like it's the similar thing here where he thinks
like, "Oh, it's bad for you to respond, right?" I think that
could come into play here 100% and explain his actions.
Do I think it Do I think it's like not a shot call? I think it's
that model. I think it's the mini trainer 300 or >> But
I I do think there are other explanations that should make a
lot of sense to Hutch, but don't. >> Yeah, that story went
the off this last week. It was crazy. It was like three days
of content like across all platforms. It was nuts. >> I
I have the perfect little story for this then because you're
like, is this worse than the 911 thing? Pisco, in the new Superman
James Gun movie, uh there's a lot of building destruction. I
don't know if any civilians die on screen, but you know, there's
some level destruction, but they had a scene where the bad guy
kicked the super dog and it was so bad with audiences they had
to cut it. They dare you hurt a dog because no matter what, hurting
a dog is ultimately worse than 9/11 apparently to in a lot of
people's audience. >> There are these little >> dude
does anybody understand like not understand this? You'd think
you'd think this would give people a little more clarity on how
a certain subset of the population views the abortion issue,
right? Where like you see something that is this why people like
get really upset about kids. It's why people get really upset
about dogs. It's something that is blameless, right? It's just
something that's blameless. Anything that's blameless that's
that that is exists without sin, that thing being hurt is the
worst thing in the world. Every adult can possibly earn bad treatment
in a lot of people's eyes. This is, by the way, like a bad belief.
You shouldn't believe that adults can like earn bad treatment
for most things. You like at least um like abusive treatments,
right? You shouldn't believe that. That's like bad. But most
people do think that way. So, this is like a sinless thing. This
cute dog,
it getting hurt is worse than basically anything else. Dude,
Palestinian kids, listen, those pal I've heard on good authority.
Those Palestinian kids stone dogs to death. Okay? I've heard
it on good authority from Briana Woo. So obviously they deserve
whatever Israel does to them. >> Little things where to
me
this kind of emotional response doesn't always right like you
would think the destruction of a city in which humans are being
killed u doesn't resonate with people as much as temporary discomfort
for a dog or a pattern of discomfort or abuse for a dog. like
but for whatever reason the human mind just um will take either
an individual case more seriously or a dog more seriously than
a human being. Uh and I don't know explanation for it. >> You're
talking very western too because if you look at there's a lot
of European cultures who who view dogs as the same as you know
every other farm animal that they'll you know kill and eat. And
so you you'll watch I mean this is I don't know if this is a
Russian thing but you know when Putin was uh uh inspecting that
dog or maybe it was the Japanese prime minister I'm not sure
but he's just you know picking it up by the scruff and just kind
of like dangling it around like this is very you know it's not
just a a human universal thing. So a lot of people don't love
dogs but
>> dude I I feel like maybe this is just growing up like
uh early 2000s. I feel like when people talk about Chinese people,
one of the one of the like slurs you would use against somebody
who is Chinese is they eat dogs, right? Like that was a way of
dehumanizing Chinese people for a long time. It probably still
is. Like they eat dogs.
So yeah, obviously it's like a huge thing in this culture to
anthropomorphize dogs. >> Americans are hey defending the
innocent doesn't understand what's happening to it uh dog. So
>> I mean also strange that he didn't check on the animal.
I know if my dog, my family member screams in pain even for a
second. I'm getting up to go see what happened. You know what
I mean? Not just staring at it like you're being dramatic. Like,
>> you know, it's not every day your dog just goes, "Ow."
You know, like something's wrong with car, bro. >> I I
don't know if you guys have pets, but there is a
>> Yeah. Nothing Nothing will wake you up faster than hearing
a pet start to dry heave. I've never bolted out of a bed from
4 in the morning hearing like a cat about to throw up somewhere
or a dog about to throw up on the bed or something. So, >> wait,
wasn't it okay? So, I feel Okay, never mind. >> Yeah, pain
absolutely should be like an instant. Oh my god, are you okay?
And that did not seem to be what happened.
>> History did not start on October 7th.
>> Oh, did it happen on It happened on >> It happened
on October 7th, bro. And they called it Doctober 7th.
>> I've also seen K911 being spammed in chat, but I don't
know if something helping that. >> Oh, no. >> I I
do want to say I don't doubt that Hassan loves his dog and has
a close relationship with that. I I'm I'm just saying that he
could use some work on his his ownership skills, it seems. But
I don't doubt that he loves the dog, and it means a lot to him.
Okay. Well, listen.
I says, "Oh, listen. I think he's just like a little undisiplined
with how he owns the dog." little that's like a totally reasonable
take by the way. You could look at that and I think that's probably
true, right? If Hassan did something to the dog when the dog
was getting off, like if he if he vibrated the collar or if he
shocked the dog, like even if it was corrective, not hurtful,
right? If he did something where he's like trying to correct
behavior when the dog's already turned around and correcting
the behavior, I do think that's like probably a little too much
given I think the reason he reaches over there if he did do it
is because he's upset about how his stream have been going. And
he said as much later on like, "Hey, I was I was upset about
my how my stream was going. I was like tilted. I should have
been nicer. I should have gone to check on her, right? It seemed
like he understood that." So, I think that's totally reasonable
take. >> Yeah. I mean, look, do you guys think this is
unforgivable?
>> Or is it is it like the lying? >> I just don't
like the lying. >> Wait, why did why did Hutch say no?
Hutch has implied in this conversation that Hassan's career is
over. This is uh
like totally He said this is a total moral failing. He said,
"Han, you shouldn't respect Yeah. Wait.
Oh, sure. Well, I guess that is Hutch's opinion as well is that
he can forgive anything
if somebody's sufficiently uh apologetic or sufficiently willing
to
Okay, fine. >> Like, it's a learning experience. You have
a big audience to say, "Look, I'm, you know, something happened
and here's what I'm going to do to prevent it from happening
from now on. It's not the end of the world." You know what I
mean? >> It's not unforgivable, but you know, like it speaks
to his character is what I'm saying. All I want to know is PC,
when is part seven of the Hassan collar gate stream going up.
>> That's fair. Okay. It's not unforgivable, but he is
a piece of >> I don't know, dude. Apparently, another clip
is going off cuz people are finding old clips of him now. So,
I guess there's a clip going nuts on LSF right now. So, I don't
know. We'll see. Maybe this is another week of content. >> This
is This is Wait, what lasts longer, Colergate or the government
shutdown?
>> Government shutdown.
>> Uh, let's see here. Colergate. Here's here's the new
clip for Colargate. Okay, another explanation from Hassan. He's
pushing the gate button and Ka reacts to it. Oh, let's look off.
I'm guessing he looks off to his left here and he presses something
and
I I guess we'll >> Guys that don't even know Ka's name
uh coming in here saying I know. I know. Can we just Can we just
move on, please? Cuz like cuz the the memes were funny in the
first couple of days, but now the only people that still are
like actively pushing it are people who are genuinely mentally
ill in the way that like anytime my arm moves around or like
I unlock the gate or some like I do have a button on my desk
for the gate, right? And I unlock the gate and obviously if you
have a dog, you know this already. When they hear that the gate
is unlocked, they perk up. They're like, "Oh my god, he shocked
her again." You know, it's just they are uh weird stalkers that
are >> I don't think Hassan's saying he was opening the
gate the other day, right? I think he's saying he's probably
saying that maybe one of the other clips where where she like
kind of jumps or something. Maybe
like I don't know. This doesn't seem to apply to the original
I I don't get the impression he's he's saying at all that this
replies or applies to the uh the original clip.
No, I don't think he's saying that either. Sweatpads freedom.
>> Yeah, I don't >> redemption to their mental illness.
And I think
and um I think it's just, you know, it is what it is, bro. They
are narrating your job. Absolutely skitsos. Yeah, it's caught.
Brandy's
This is going to be a post on its own again. And I know anytime
I bring anytime I bring anything up
uh uh anytime I even address this like people go nutty over it.
So
>> I don't think he means it a future time.
>> I think somebody I think there are other clips Hutch
said there are other clips where he like leans over to grab like
where Ka moves and he leans over to like grab something on that
side and Ka like kind of reacts.
That's that's what Hutch said. So, I'm guessing Han saw maybe
one of those Hutch clips and is trying to explain what happened
in another one of those clips. >> Too much energy. I know,
but like chatters also are like, "Oh, this happened, that happened,
whatever." Um,
yeah. In any case, in any case, in any
where was I? You're creating employment. True, true, true, true,
true, true,
Jamie question. How do you deal with this level of psychosis
directed towards you? Um,
I don't know. I'm stubborn.
Wow.
How do you do it, Han? How are you so strong, Hassan? How many
times does his story change now? I mean, it dude,
it's very interesting watching people divert from reality like
so quickly, right? like how quickly you get super far away from
what reality is.
Huzzan, can you tell me how you were always the Hassan? Can you
tell me how you were like so, you know, how are you so blameless
and sinless in every possible situation? Huzz, how are you, how
are you so amazing? How do you handle it? How do you handle it?
How do you do it, man? I don't know. I don't get it.
Uh it's it's just very funny watching these people like break
from reality. though so harshly. Why would he push the gate button
when he's telling her to go again?
I don't know how you could Can somebody explain to me how you'd
hear this one and think that he's referring to the previous clip
and like that's what there's just no possible way you could think
that's what he's doing here.
Uh that that comment from the glazing chatter is pretty pretty
gross though. Pretty weird. Pretty odd odd stuff.
Let's see. Maybe somebody posts another one of the clips in here.
Hold on. Let me uh let me check the thread real
It's a vibration collar. I was reaching for a zen. It's a gate
button. Predictions on what lies next? Yeah, I I assume he's
talking about a different
I'm looking for anything.
Man, if somebody knew where that hutch clip was or the like the
hutch instance of him going through and trying to find those
uh
find those other instances,
but I don't know how to go find his stream. So,
okay. Okay. Okay. Let's um
>> What are we looking for here?
>> We're done. Oh, hold on. We can actually >> Sure.
This will be This will be probably dead by Wednesday or Thursday.
Well, I'm I'm uh flying down to TwitchCon on uh Friday and staying
with a friend and he he works with the government and so if the
shutdown's still happening, we get to spend more time together.
So maybe we can extend it a couple more days. Yeah. >> Wait,
huh? >> Wait, where's TwitchCon this year? >> San
Diego. >> Oh, okay. >> I thought it was going to
be in LA. That's where all the Twitchers are. But
>> uh Yeah. No, if you swing by LA, give me a call. We
can get some lunch or >> Yeah, I'm definitely going to
go by LA at some point. if not uh for TwitchCon. But yeah, sounds
good. All right,
>> thank you
Libs for >> just regular streams. So, tomorrow 8:30 a.m.
11 last week um disagreeing with my takes and so >> do
you do you need a moderator for this uh this back and forth?
>> Hold on. >> I know. I asked her if she wanted
to fight because I saw her >> need a moderator. >> Hold
on. What is this? What is >> You know what? I think I'm
I'm having a conversation with Aaron with straight raid at some
point.
>> Uh oh.
That's going to be funny, dude. Oh, I have to see Pisco's reaction.
>> Yeah, he knows. He knows. He knows. >> You know
what? I think I'm I'm having a conversation with Aaron with Straighter
at some point uh this week. >> When's that happening? >> I
know. I asked her if she wanted to fight because
>> I saw her in the uh comments last week um disagreeing
with my takes. And so, >> do you do you need a moderator
for this uh this back and forth? Cuz I got to say I I sometimes
hesitate to jump in when you and Pisco are fighting because because
I don't want to poke the Why would Why would anybody want you
to be a moderator between him and Aaron? You are like objectively
all the way on his side. That would be a crazy moderator.
It's like, hey, uh and Churchill are going to have a debate.
Who do you guys want to moderate? You want Gerbles to moderate?
No. No. Obviously, you want somebody who's like a bit more moderate
between the two positions to moderate. >> The bear. But
I >> not that Hutch and Not that Hutch and Soy Pill are
like Gerbles. Okay. It was just an example. >> I I wouldn't
mind uh observing that. That sounds like a lot of fun. >> I
mean, we had like a 2hour conversation a month ago where, you
know, it was we disagreed, but it didn't get nuts. Like she's
not like >> Oh, is that about the the DNC stuff? >> I
think I think so. Yeah, it was about that and other stuff, but
she's not like belligerent. I disagree with her on a lot of stuff,
but she's not like crazy or anything.
Uh, Aaron is more belligerent than me in every possible way,
by the way. I'm just going to throw that out there. All right.
I'm blocked by Hutch on Twitter. I tried to reach out to Hutch
for a conversation. Aaron is more belligerent than me in every
possible way. Aaron, if you're watching right now, you know that's
true. This is insane cope from Hutch right now. >> Okay.
Well, let me know if you want someone to listen in on that. Uh,
IRI, what's going on with you?
>> I'm actually doing a one-on-one debate on Thursday.
Hey, I don't even know who it's against, but it's going to be
on Modern Day debates about uh Ice and the job Ice has been doing.
So, that should be interesting. Um, and then this weekend I'll
be in Vegas for the When We Were Young festival with the Offspring.
So, that's
>> And, uh, who are you debating on this uh, modern day
debate? >> I honestly have no idea. I I I really >> uh
I think I think um
uh anybody listen anybody suggesting that Hutch is like straight
away or like that's that's not a thing. They're they're actually
friends. Okay. They're actually friends. That's just weird. Don't
be weird. You don't have to be weird about it. Okay. He's not
looking to get in or something like that. It's not like that.
Okay. Don't be weird about it. >> Really don't know who
my debate partner is. I just know I'm debating some
>> I don't care who they are. I know they >> don't
matter to me. Yeah, just give me two hours to get my talking
points out and pound on some conservative, I guess.
>> Okay, Pisco, what's going on with you? >> Yeah,
so I had some stuff in the background been working on over the
weekend. We'll divulge at an appropriate time, but um I'm editing
videos now as well as my editor and so expect to see more videos
coming on the main YouTube channel and follow me on Tik Tok and
on Instagram at peaceke stuff coming there as well. So, um, a
lot of [__] happening. Um, released and announced
hopefully soon. But, um, yeah, >> it's always funny when
you and me go at it and then he edits a video for each of us.
We have the same editor. >> Our editor. Yeah. So, it's
like, um, it's funny whenever we have a fight in unlive and learn.
He's basically, you know, profiting off of both sides of it,
which is great. >> On your thumbnail, it'll be like, I
don't know what he says. Crazy, you know. Yeah. Yeah. whoever
the the one that's supposed to be on the back foot's always like
>> and then you know Pisco says I I am the straightfaced
logical one and you are living out right now. You look so
I I've
>> uh I don't think
I feel like I feel like Pisco's got to
Pisco's got to be doing well enough with this that he could pay
multiple editors. I feel like but maybe not. Maybe I'm I don't
know what his financial situation is. So, you know, hard for
me to actually speculate. It feels that way, but I don't know.
>> Realize that it's it's so easy to >> Oh, I hold
on.
This is actually a good point. Uh, never mind. I forgot the bar
for like making it as a creator in NYC is way different than
out in the boonies. So, >> any conversation to find one
image of some guy looking absolutely deranged.
>> But, yeah. >> All right. Well, on my end, I've
got the Cars for Ukraine fundraiser and most of the descriptions
of all of my streams. So, please go check that out if you want
to help buy trucks for the Ukrainian resistance. Otherwise, I'm
streaming semi-regularly this week and uh working on some vids.
I might do some stuff at TwitchCon. So, thanks for tuning in
everybody. We need a catchphrase, guys. What's our catch? Like,
you know, like a sign off and we're like and and like you know,
lib. >> All right. All right. We're done. We're done with
this. This is over. We're good. We're good to go.